Well, we've seen another really resounding
defeat for the anti-abortion crowd.
The Supreme Court yesterday said that, no,
you can't require in Louisiana on doctors
who perform abortions to have admitting privileges
at area hospitals, that this effectively violates
Roe v. Wade, which is the precedent of note
and thus reminds us why this question of Roe
v. Wade comes up so often when new potential
Supreme Court justices are being vetted and
questioned.
And what is particularly interesting about
this decision is that it was a five four decision
where the five the majority was made up of
the four more liberal justices and Chief Justice
John Roberts, a moderate conservative.
Certainly no doubt about it.
And we're going to talk more about Chief Justice
John Roberts and his legacy and his sort of
place within the Supreme Court on Thursday.
But for today, I want to talk about this decision
that this really is an important defeat for
the anti choice movement that seeks to just
ban abortion, make abortion illegal, despite
the reality, of course, that banning abortion
reduces legal abortion, maybe at least in
the state where it's banned.
But it does not actually reduce the number
of women who figure out a way to terminate
a pregnancy.
And that's another story that we've talked
about quite a bit on this program.
So the reason this is an important decision
is that this is a common way to try to restrict
access to abortion the way it works in this
Louisiana law that was struck down by the
Supreme Court yesterday.
And in other states, the game that they play
essentially is you.
You don't ban abortion, per say, but you require
doctors who perform abortions to have admitting
privileges at nearby hospitals.
And the anti-abortion people say that this
is that the reason you do this is, well, if
a doctor performs an abortion and the patient
needs to be hospitalized, it's important that
the doctor have admitting privileges so that
that doctor can continue providing care in
the hospital for the hospitalized abortion
patient.
Now, all of this is part of the ruse that
includes making abortion seem like a far more
risky medical procedure than it actually is.
So a few realities that we should keep in
mind.
Number one, hospitalizations after abortion
are very, very rare.
Number two.
Even if one were necessary a hospitalization,
the patient would still be able to get care,
even if the doctor that performed the abortion
doesn't have admitted admitting privileges
at the local hospital.
And number three, there are bureaucratic reasons
that sometimes make it difficult for doctors
who perform abortions to get those admitting
privileges.
So this is essentially a trick from the anti
choice crowd to make abortions more difficult
to obtain and maybe to dissuade people from
seeking them out in general.
So so understand how crazy this is.
Five doctors in all of Louisiana provide abortions.
Two of them have obtained admitting privileges.
One in New Orleans and one in Shreveport.
The Shreveport doctor says he can't handle
all of the work alone.
And the trial judge concluded that what this
law, in effect, does is reduce Louisiana to
a single doctor in a single clinic in New
Orleans.
And that is in practice a violation of Roe
v. Wade.
That is ultimately what the Supreme Court
found, that the Roe v. Wade decision from
1973, which is the precedent for so much of
the discussion about abortion today, would
in practice be violated if this law requiring
admitting privileges at local hospitals were
to remain the law of the land.
So this is relevant for a few different reasons.
Number one, Chief Justice John Roberts, a
George W. Bush appointee, previously favored
abortion restrictions in two other abortion
related cases.
We're going to talk more about him momentarily.
But in this case, John Roberts coming over
with the majority in defense of abortion rights.
Number two, this is huge because everything
is just going wrong for this administration.
Donald Trump, as you may know, now claims
to be against abortion.
He was in favor of a woman's right to choose,
I believe his for 67 or 68 years of life.
His evangelical followers have fallen for
it hook, line and sinker.
I guess they believe Trump is now against
abortion.
And this is another decision that goes against
Donald Trump stated wishes.
If we believe that those are actually his
which wishes.
Now, let's talk about Chief Justice John Roberts,
because this is really, for me, the crux of
the discussion that now is going on on Friday.
I'm sorry, on Thursday.
I'm going to get into more detail about whether
Chief Justice John Roberts is a moderate or
a conservative.
Of course, he was selected by George W. Bush.
But what I really want you to understand about
this decision and the decision on Dacca last
week where John Roberts was also on the side
of we're not going to remove Dacca for the
reason the Trump administration wants it removed.
These are technical decisions.
These are not decisions where John Roberts
is coming over to the left, so to speak, on
the merits of abortion or on the merits of
DACA.
What I mean by that is in the dock, a case,
for example, the Trump administration just
bungled their case.
The Trump administration tried to end DACA
by saying Barack Obama didn't have the authority
to put DACA in place via executive order.
The Supreme Court said that's not a good argument.
The Supreme Court, John Roberts, they correctly
found that Obama did not overstep authority,
but it was not a decision on the merits of
DACA.
And similarly with this abortion decision,
John Roberts is saying, in a technical sense,
the Louisiana law would violate the precedent
set by Roe v. Wade.
It's a technical decision.
It's not a decision on the merits.
Now, will we take it?
Of course we will.
But what's important to understand, I mean,
look at even the LGBT discrimination case.
Roberts correctly identified in a technical
sense, if you allow.
An employer to discriminate on the basis of
sexual orientation or gender identity.
By definition, it is a discriminatory act
on the basis of sex which is banned.
So what John Roberts did.
It doesn't mean he made the wrong decisions.
It means he is simply getting the technical
question right.
It shows us actually how insane the court
is that these decisions were not nine to zero.
This decision on abortion should have been
nine to zero.
The law that Louisiana wanted to pass on abortion
obviously violates Roe v. Wade.
It should have been a nine zero decision.
So the message here should not be who cares
about judges?
We got the right decision anyway.
Even with Chief Justice John Roberts, who
came over and joined the liberal majority,
the decision should have been nine to zero
and it shouldn't come down to one center.
Right justice deciding.
Oh, precedent matters.
Precedent matters.
That's why we need Joe Biden and not Donald
Trump choosing more justices, because this
should have been should have been a nine zero
decision.
And then on Thursday, we're going to talk
a little bit more, sort of about the political
orientation of Chief Justice John Roberts
and other justices on the court.